der schmutzigste prozess des jahres er
ist hollywood reif und strotzt nur so
vor schockmomenten amber heard und
johnny depp schein nicht sich ordentlich
ein zusammen bei der schlammschlacht des
jahres das sind die sechs krassesten
momente des prozesses
schockmoment johnny depp erzählt dass im
amber instead gekackt hause
auf meiner seite des bettes waren
menschliche fäkalien
figur
talk sms embers anwalt verliest eine
textnachricht die johnny an einen freund
schickte der inhalt brutal
ist sie sagen lasst sie uns ertränken
bevor wir sie verbrennen mit 3 ausrufen
nachdem sie sagen lasst sie uns
ertränken bevor wir sie verbrennen sagen
sie ich werde ihrem toten körper
vergewaltigen um sicher zu gehen dass
sie tot ist
schock schilderung amber erzählt wie
johnny misshandelte wenn er getrunken
und auf drogen war er hat meine brüste
angequatscht meine oberschenkel dann hat
er meine unterwäsche zerrissen und
fingen an meinen intimbereich zu
untersuchen
ich wusste nicht was ich machen sollte
ich stand nur da während er mit seinen
fingern um wühlte
und auch sonst waren des alkohol- und
drogen-eskapaden schwer zu ertragen er
brach bewusstlos zusammen lag in seiner
eigenen kotze er hatte keinerlei
kontrolle über seinen körper und jeder
räumte immer hinter ihm auch ich räumte
hinter ihm auf
schock geständnis in eine audioaufnahme
wird deutlich wie aggressiv amber heard
war
[Musik]
sag es ihnen johnny sag ihnen ich johnny
bin opfer häuslicher gewalt es wäre ein
fairer kampf wir werden sehen wie viele
menschen hier glauben würden
schock video ein völlig betrunkener
johnny depp und amber die ihn ohne sein
wissen films du willst verrückten kannst
du haben komplett verrückt
hast du die ganze flasche heute morgen
betrunken
du fühlst du das recht
[Musik]
rosenkrieg in hollywood vielmehr
schlammschlacht geht nicht